I'm Sara hey Encounters morning hey sir  how you doing a show where I look behind  the strange world of online personal ads  what is their story  who are these people so subscribe and  join me on this journey you never know  who you might need next hello  Oh ever since I turned 40 I lost my  inspiration I have no joy I'm having a  hard time what am i doing trying to make  the films that I used to make what if I  make a documentary and this is where you  come in I have no idea what I'm stepping  in Terry walk together I believe we will  make that Erin is that you you are  inspiring feelings in me I don't know  what to do yeah this is gonna be a good  day very excited about it okay  [Music]  are you ready to go wow your tough nut  to crack  [Music]  you